oh that was through should we talk about
business down here oh no no business
stuff baby i could have just i know why
now well yeah i get why we don't have to
talk about that no i can talk about it
okay because i'm not gonna say any bad
thing bad what are you guys is this the
fbi
i i want to say things
listen i want to say things because i
don't do don't do that no no you have
notoriously the biggest mouth and i've
sucked off my cousins let's [ __ ] get
real
let's get real get real and [ __ ] real
but i i i also feel responsible for
making sure you don't get extorted you
don't like i'm i'm responsible for
protecting you because you've never had
a podcast before and you've never had
free reign like this before and it's a
dangerous setting for somebody who has
diarrhea of the mouth like you so so you
know i've been in trouble for a long
time for my diary of the mouth and um
i've paid heavy consequences of it
and that's why right now i'm editing as
we speak everything that i'm saying
right now i'm editing
but um
and i want to
i want to get sentimental a little bit
but oh good
what do it i want to uh what is that a
thumb drive no
it's a vape i just quit smoking he's oh
cool bobby's got a thumb
that is a thumb drive though yeah yeah
it sure it is it's actually how you
charge it too
oh usb can you put it with usb all right
yeah yeah that's cool but i wanted to
thank you because you were really
i'm being real
you were really nice to me when i we
were buddies i understand that but you
really brought me in
and you were the only one that gave me
the your number like i didn't talk to
mike mcdonald for three years
you know
i don't think i ever really even talked
to stephanie
stephanie where we are yeah she would
say hi and stuff but i just yeah it's
definitely not very talk yeah
moe was nice that was very nice alex was
very nice to you when she was very know
because she was leaving though yeah
and i remember when alex when i got on
the show and she was like her last week
oh yeah she goes this was the biggest
mistake of your life doing the show
why really i go what she goes yeah you
[ __ ] up what and i go okay bye yeah
yeah i mean that's literally she pulled
me aside and said that really deborah
was nice everyone come on
aries wasn't that nice
mike was very combative with me
combative yeah you probably you probably
had a lot of the same bits and sketches
and stuff i don't know probably thought
you were biting as [ __ ]
um
uh but you were really nice people
stephanie is so super sweet i'm not
saying they're not
sweet
moses a person in the world no mo was
very nice yeah moses but you're the one
that would call me like how are you and
stuff like that i would never call you
and be like how worried
[Laughter]
i just put in my eyes
yeah like you invited me to a party a
couple parties we were pals i think we
were fast friends and then i betrayed
you how did you betray me remember when
you left and you called me a bunch of
times i never called you back yeah but
that's just because you're you i i
called you for like two or three years
and never heard back three years so i
have more like two years let's say it
was probably two years and then uh but
every time i called you after a while i
realized you were just would not get
back to me so then i started leaving uh
messages as frank caliendo's
impersonation
yeah yeah or one time you answered and i
was like yeah
but that's that wasn't a frank orlando
impression it wasn't a personal thing it
was just that's just the way i am and i
just feel and i try to change that about
myself like when
we know don't worry about it nobody uh
everyone knows you're weird
no but
i thought i think that we're better now
you and i yeah we're good friends now
yeah we're good friends now yeah but
we're both you know that was a long time
ago we're both in our 50s
here's the thing about you and i'm going
to say something real about you and i'm
going to say something that you're not
going to like
and it might cause a fight okay if i'm
going to say it anyway because i love
you you're a room okay
i don't want to be like any other [ __ ]
you are missing
right
hundreds of thousands of dollars
by not doing stand-up
you it is an ability
okay it is an ability that you have
i've seen you go up live you opened for
me at irvine remember that one time as a
character david greco opened for you i
saw it i understand that but
if will sasso did it yeah you could make
so much money i've told you why i don't
like stand up for me rosenbaum does it
who michael rosenbaum
who's that
lex luthor on the smallville you don't
know michael oh yeah he's a friend of
yours yeah yeah i know who he is
i don't know he should note
those
those two should know each other he acts
michael rosenbaum's out there i thought
you were talking i don't know who you're
talking about
but uh yeah i know who that might yeah
but
it's a [ __ ]
it's a chunk of money that you're
missing it's it's a part of i know but
you don't have to do it that's fine
you're never going to no no no you know
why you're not going to do it because
you're [ __ ] weak yeah you're [ __ ]
you live in fear and you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh no
you're going to do it now
so i'll tell you what smiley at the
character why are you smiling
what camera just look at the mirror is
that having a camera yes
he's doing it to the camera that's the
real tiger belly there's like a [ __ ]
show he's doing to a hole in the wall
like andy kaufman is a 10 year old he's
like looking around like there's an
audience full of people here oh he's
[ __ ] hallucinating what's happening
he's so happy with himself and he's
looking he's getting it from the
audience in the mirror here's the thing
i have great respect for stand up i love
stand up i've always you know we had all
the albums when i was growing up i had
an older brother and sister so my tastes
were sort of you know uh
uh
you know sort of uh helped along by them
you know we had the carlin and all the
[ __ ] and uh gilda live that was a good
one great that on uh on eight track um
and steve martin of course so
uh
anyway anyway so here's my thing
i don't you know me i don't really like
to go up in front of people and talk and
give my opinion it's not interesting to
me i think it's i think it's uh i think
that's oversaturated i think that your
uh profession as a comedian is under
siege by [ __ ] with inflated egos
who think just holding a microphone and
flapping their [ __ ] gums into it is
something and it's not uh and i feel
like artistically i want to and i strive
to even though you know we all try to
make things and they don't always work
out or whatever but i'm always working
on something that no one's ever going to
see and it's been that way for a long
time i don't know that just getting up
in front of people and going
you know i don't know i don't want to
i'm not trying to [ __ ] on stand-up uh at
all i love stand-up i love funny stan i
i watch a lot of uh who's the guy i
watch that guy uh
uh dave
chappelle yeah oh and uh
i also watched the the black guy
again yeah i saw his stuff well
you listened to both chappelle is that
the same guy no two different guys oh
yeah yeah yeah so i've seen his i've
seen their their netflix dave chappelle
and ronaldo chapelle
yeah uh
wouldn't that be funny if dave chappelle
had like another spell like like
gallagher too
yeah yeah that'd be cool okay so anyway
but um yeah so thank you for the
encouraging words that wasn't
and i'm not gonna say i wasn't being
encouraging i know you're just being
real it's bobby being real
bobby b and bob
when klyla doesn't want to do this
anymore that's gonna be the name of your
podcast bobby b and bob and you're not
gonna go for jokes just gonna be serious
as [ __ ] and you're gonna have a bunch of
like you know doctor drew like
guests
uh and you're just gonna talk seriously
but no i i would love to do you know i
was having this well okay i've had this
conversation before with other people
who i respect immediately like yourself
who have taken the time to say do you
say do you say [ __ ] your things thank
you okay and uh
who have said oh well you should be
doing some more live [ __ ] i totally want
to i just don't know what that is okay
because i don't want to bobby i'm
telling you
i don't
don't cut me off don't don't shut me
down and go you don't have to do it you
don't have to do it because that's you
being fearful you don't want to hear the
end of what i'm saying oh [ __ ] this one
this guy wants to get confrontational
yeah i'll get caught you want to get
confrontational you want to get real
give a [ __ ] you want to get real i'll
paint myself like a [ __ ] orca and
swim in the shark festival i'll go
mystique i'm not afraid i'll go mystique
you're not going mysterio maybe a
jellyfish go inside the ocean hole
you're going to get so transparent
people can see right ocean holes oh
that's a great thing
anyway you were a very um pleasurable
guest i really really enjoyed you i
really did immensely and um
i've had um
many people on the show
and you were probably one of my biggest
surprises
oh thank you man i just don't i don't
really i'm not no no i'm being real i
really enjoyed it
i really enjoyed you i took it genuinely
yeah
not being real
i mean i don't know i don't know what
kind of game you're playing i'm not
playing any games i game you're playing
right now i literally meant that i think
i was like what i mean
what i was trying to mean is this i
legitimately mean there's no sarcasm
either so i'm just saying that you were
a really really good guest all right all
right
all right
uh we just mind
you you're just you know i'll be honest
with you man you you're just really just
a
surprise why
because um when i got the show
i googled you
you know i mean i watched stuff you know
me and google just to see
you know and then meeting you
um we had dinner that one night right
and you just you just unlike what i
thought you were going to be like that's
nice in a great way
you know
because you see you know you see a lot
of these guys that are um
you know you're a leading man you know
whatever you've done things before you
know what i mean and whatnot people know
who you are
and usually sometimes they just your
people become [ __ ] or you know
what i mean and you're just like you
don't seem like
you're an actor really
no i'm being real
this is me being
sentimental and and trying to give
compliments i'm not going to compliment
you i mean i'm not going to take him
[ __ ] you and i all right we're going
to see each other at work
okay we're gonna have our random meals
mm-hmm maybe with the cast and whatnot
mm-hmm
for birthdays holidays we'll do a text
yeah with a santa claus like emoji or
whatever
[Laughter]
and then um you know and then when we
write our books 50 years from now yeah
there'll be a couple of chapter
paragraphs yeah so yeah that's good
that's it that's good enough
that's good enough nice to live with you
you know because that's good you know
what let me say this well all right
it's reality it's it's reality you know
yeah you do these things everyone's like
you know everyone becomes a family
quickly and then you know well let's
keep in touch and never do it dude
here's another thing i want to say to
say about that this is that
god
i just want to say this say it
don't be afraid
when i was on the last to come i was on
animal practice it was with justin kirk
tyler levine i liked all i liked them
too
and we did lose contact
you know i would have dinner with just
you know just you just
right
so
literal i'm being real
if in in case
we lose contact right
and you know disbands or whatnot
i i honestly believe and i want to say
this right now it was a pleasure working
with you
you [ __ ] helped me out so much dude
it might i had some meltdowns that that
the producers didn't really know they
don't know right no yeah it's only to
you right the producers are like oh we
got it let's move on whatever right
but with you i just want to say thank
you so much
i couldn't just i couldn't have
asked for a better number one in the
call sheet number two number two number
two all right yeah
number two jenna you're great too yeah
you're great but
my scenes are always with all of you
pretty much yeah so um well thank you i
i want to thank you it was a pleasure
working with you
um
hopefully
yeah
hopefully
everyone listening if you want oliver
and i have a friendship you've got to
keep right you got to
our friendship's about to die
right without your [ __ ] viewership
and i know we're watching um whatever on
netflix we don't have time just [ __ ]
watch it you pieces of [ __ ] yeah
the kind of entertainment that we give
you here on tiger belly
for free yeah it's free right yeah do we
charge people for this thing i think
it's zero dollars zero dollars
fan market oh okay but you know it's
it's bur i just wanted to say this is
that you know before
you know i'll be honest with you before
you know i did your cook show
we didn't really talk a lot we didn't
have really a relationship and i've
always wanted to i always whenever i saw
your work
or
i saw you around and went you know
that's the kind of guy that i think that
i could be friends with
and i'm just really glad that you came
over i really got to know you more
you're a good guy
and i just think that you're a
heavyweight and i think um that there's
going to be a lot coming from you and
you're you're
you're i'm being real i appreciate you
you're you're one of those guys and i'm
serious about being your swimmer on the
triathlon she doesn't leave with she's
amazing if we leave with anything
swimmer runner biker i was on the
philippine national team and i also swam
division one i'm in
i ran a marathon with no training
yeah yeah yeah i don't know how to ride
a bike
we only we usually our podcast is only
an hour long and we did
a long couple hours
yeah
yeah but i but i
i knew this was gonna happen like i do i
have such a connection with you when i
first met you
i i knew that you you disconnect when
you meet people the way i do like yeah
and then everyone no but i'm gonna say
this though and i and i don't give a
[ __ ] what you say right now
this is the real
is is that from now on
this is different
no
what i'm saying is when i see you it's
not gonna be oh there's bird i have to
be nice to him because he's the [ __ ] and
i'm with all things comedy or whatever
yeah now it's like bert he's my friend
no no i i've yeah i i feel like i've i
felt like that when i came here tonight
and then after we did the cooking show
yeah that was the beginning of the
foundation you were god you were so
[ __ ] funny it was fun and we'll you
know
but if somebody said to me hey bomb is
one of the strongest asian comedians in
the country i wouldn't be offended you
wouldn't
no because i'm not this one of the
strongest comics in the country
[Laughter]
i know that
there's probably a hundred dudes better
than me
dan
we got to take him out of the shrine you
got to take him out of this shrine
best friends
[Music]
i remember going to
auditions and you'd be like worried
about dot fans
going in before
please tell more i'm sorry i think i
shouldn't say that
please tell us more tell us everything
please please i just remember that yeah
i remember bobby like pacing and looking
at the board and seeing like
that fan came in
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you still pretty worried about him
they're close we're pretty close yeah
yeah you know i'm really friends now
yeah i think yeah no yeah nobody you're
not he blocked me on instagram
why did he block you
because bobby was obsessed well can we
talk about it no kalala is obsessing
well i won't say anything well
kalila had he took the brunt of your
obsession and he blocked me i see i have
an obsession with him he's playing
hollywood so he won't block bobby but
he's doing like i have an obsession with
i've always had an obsession with him i
know i remember
and but i said to her
to you exude or you i want you to
deliver this deliver my obsession and
i'm not going to the world because i
don't want him to not like me
you don't want anyone to not like you
[Music]
that's so weird that you say that
it's because you're right
why am i like that i already told you
why because you didn't get enough love
from your father
and
and you also i mean you're also you also
have a talent
and you could just be your disposition
in general
i i think this is a opportune moment for
me to um
this is real i want to say something
very real i'm about to cry
no you're not i know because i haven't
cried in a long time but
i um and as these people know you know
these are my family this is my family
here
and you know
rarely
you know i you know i've been in a lot
of things you know i've done you know
i'm a sitcom now i've you know i've done
things i've done some movies and stuff
and whatnot and um
you're very popular i f
i was so bad on your show
it gave me nightmares what show
yes and he said i couldn't say briny
deep
it gave me it traumatized me yeah the
word bryony the phrase briny had
forgotten about that but i just remember
you were funny did you watch it no it
was good
i know but the thing is is that
i knew here's the thing though is that
for some reason
that day because it's you and mosha i
wanted to do such a great job because
you guys i love you guys so i really do
love i've always loved you guys
i i loved you guys even before you guys
were even together because i used to see
moshe at you know around town when he he
was friends with my brother before i was
friends with him because when he first
moved here he wasn't
like he was trying to get in you know
and um i just i've always just really
liked him and his stand-up is so smart
and he's such a good comic and i think i
i just
think so highly on of you in fact yes in
fact
that [ __ ] show that show that what's
that game show that with byron to allen
that byron island oh have you done that
the reason why i did it
is they go i go who's done it they got
louie anderson i love louie and all
these people
yeah it seems a little they go natasha's
done i'll do it then
you're the reason why right you're the
reason why i even [ __ ] did that
because you
are like hips in my mind and how i feel
about you so i'm like you know that's
okay to do
but um
here's the voi i i'm being real right
now and um you know i'm a liar i'm a
deceiver
and i i do shadow play sometimes but
every once in a while there's truisms
when i say things there's truisms and
i'm very real
and you're gonna have a real moment
right now okay
honest to god
out of all the comics i've met
especially in our class of guys because
you're in the same classes i know i know
i look young and people think that i'm
in my 20s still but um we're in the same
class okay
you're you you're probably one of the
best souls
i've met i mean you and i
i've always just you're an honest guy
you're you're a hard worker and um
you're a nice guy
and it's a shame that there's your
daughter's out there and she doesn't get
to know
the great joey diaz i think you're a
great guy and i think it's a loss for
her
you know i think i would really wish
that she reached out to you
and and developed a relationship because
you're a great guy also i know this for
a fact too is that because i've asked
around is joey diaz a good father to his
five-year-old daughter yeah you guys go
to the park
i talked to her the other day when i
called you remember
hey go talk to say hi to um
your uncle bobby and she go hi
she said
hi uncle bobby
right this guy's legit dude i gotta say
it really hurts my feelings that she
that happened i got a second chance okay
do you know what that's like in life
yeah i've had third chances yeah i mean
to have a second chance i got to have a
kid at 50.
that's incredible so
whoever's controlling the cards buddha
uh jesus christ jesus whatever the [ __ ]
is controlling the cards the big picture
yeah replace that gap in my life yeah
for right now i'm cool move on but i
just wanted to say welcome back
yes okay
it's really good to see you back it's
good to see joe rogan hold on let me
tell you something else okay let me tell
you why i went back why just so you know
i work on science i got the call from
adam on a friday
that that [ __ ] stunt tommy wasn't
there no more and he was taking over the
store would i consider coming back
and i said i'll call you next week let
me think about it
and i had a colonoscopy
that's when they stick a camera into
your ass
and that night i stayed up drinking that
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] go lightly and you
drink it and the movie was on that movie
with peter sellers being there being
there that was marilyn martinez's
favorite movie that's my favorite movie
and i watched that movie and i said
that's a sign for marilyn
to go back to the store oh your boy
there you go [ __ ] you wanna do
don't leave yet
they make me cry yes no that's a true
story that was god
that was god that was marilyn marilyn
was the one in her death bed that in the
middle of a rant in the middle of a rant
about jesus and that if she
got beat the cancer she was wasn't going
to work dirty again in the middle of a
rant
she stopped and looked at me and she
goes joey you got to stop doing coke
and i probably stopped
three weeks later i went for an
interview for a movie
and they told me we really want you for
this movie but we understand you have a
drug problem we don't have a big budget
i was so embarrassed that somebody else
knew about my little secret
that i'm like i can't do this no more
and i was about 44 and i read somewhere
that john gotti had taken over the
gambino crime family when he was 45. so
i said i got to do something when i'm
45.
and i've been clean from coke for 10
years
there you have it
if god he could take over the gambinos
in 45 i had to do something my life for
45. no we do no we do this thing at the
end where we do um god joey you
get so emotional you got so emotional
yeah bro we're talking this is holding
to heart here this ain't no [ __ ] okie
doke podcast i don't do podcasts
i know that i just said yeah i'm real
too no that's why i'm saying that don't
call me okay i love you i love you too
now we do this thing called unhelpful
advice we'll do it really quickly we
have an email and then we give
suggestions and then we'll end it okay
go ahead unhelpful advice with bobby
kalila and joey coco diaz
my father-in-law equals amazing loving
supportive and love seeing him always
his wife slash mother-in-law equals
attic